big day in sports las vegas is on a very
short list now to host super bowl
58 and our city will now host the 2022
nfl pro bowl it's a great win
sports director chris matthews spoke
with raiders owner mark davis about the
possibility
of that super bowl landing right here in
las vegas chris that's right denise
it's a win it's a win-win for sure the
timing couldn't be better that virus
has absolutely crippled las vegas and a
chance to bring a super bowl here
to help the city economically recover
that's big we caught up with raiders
owner mark davis
and he's excited he knows what our city
means to the nfl
they all do a decision on a host city
for super bowl 58
will be made in 2021 well
you know as i said when we were coming
here that you're getting more than a
football team you're getting more than
the power of the raiders you get the
power of the nfl
and that's being shown all these other
events that we're bringing here
with the draft the pro bowl and
hopefully now in 2024
to bring the super bowl and yeah it will
be it'll mean a lot to the community
as a whole because something like that
it's not i mean that's
that's hundreds of million in economic
benefits
well it's everything really it's
eyeballs it's everything chris
and uh las vegas is worthy of it and
we're going to put on one of the best
shows anybody's ever seen
also the nfl will put together a new pro
bowl promo the league announcing today
that its
pro bowl in las vegas will be pushed
back to 2022 which means
las vegas will host the pro bowl in the
winter and the nfl draft that spring
also